these are specific spots we're going to
be shopping for so
five bucks
okay
cute smile
s perfect
uh and then it's the water line tile
which is going to be here
it's all
which is really cool because when they
told me I needed to pick outside I was
like what the [__] I don't know what I'm
doing so the fact that they were they
provided pictures and told me where the
towel is going
um I'm stoked because I feel like the
task felt this big and now it feels this
big
so some of these tiles look really
familiar I would say at our old house in
Glendora remember that one I think we
went with uh something like more of this
blue look one of these guys and what's
cool about those is I think those will
be more cost efficient but it does look
a little bit more like Cookie Cutter
like you've seen a lot of pools like
that with our pool we're trying to make
it look really unique as you guys know
our uh inspo is modern Mediterranean so
we want it to look very like Greek
Santorini or Tulum like almost like a
resort so that puts us in this ballpark
the problem is
if you look at that word marvel it's
kind of expensive right Mama
[Music]
tell you right now it is fine take a
picture
[Music]
so how we like to work is when we take a
bunch of options per like area so then
that way when we meet with our pool
person we can go okay which one is like
over budget which is within budget
what's under budget and then based off
that we can kind of like slowly narrow
down our choices because if we just go
with based off our eyes Muhammad has
really good taste which also usually
means expensive
I hate me sometimes I don't want it to
be expensive I wanted to I wish my eyes
would see stuff that was way more
affordable and I'm like oh that's sick
and it's like oh that's the cheapest one
the most inexpensive one here and I'm
like [__] yeah but no usually they're
like that's our high-end model I'm like
[__]
we have good taste that's how you pick
me I
guess I mean I do use glasses now when
we met I wasn't wearing glasses
so when you didn't have glasses you
picked the right one
[Music]
method and I think this is way better
than what I was even thinking I'm just
way too subtle and too shy probably
doesn't give a [__] you take space look
at this guy nobody told them he could do
this but nobody told him he can't do it
so he's doing it so I want to like
I like it
any other materials you want to look at
I'm looking around not gonna lie
pretty intimidating
because we don't have the
overall aesthetic of the pool actually I
do have that on my phone can you hold
this for me
because those pictures are just pictures
of the places that's not even our pool
yeah I know so we should have asked you
if you brought it so maybe I asked you
in my head I think I have it on my phone
I should look at it to kind of get the
overall feel and then we can know I know
the feel because I'm the one that picks
so I'm pretty excited so you're not
because I feel like like um lost oh you
don't feel lost you feel like yes okay
then I'll just follow your lead there
okay
I just had to take a picture of this one
what do you like about this one um so I
know travertine is pretty
so that I want yeah
um from just different areas on this
floor and then I'll submit it and then
I'll ask him to price it out and then at
that point at least I have all these
options of Alternatives yeah and then
hopefully one of them hits the price
point is this travertine
that might be a more uh budget friendly
approach yeah because I mean you know
with going into any big project you
should budget so we did budget and we
want to make sure we stick to that
budget oh yeah still hitting the vision
yeah
um so yeah I just want to get options so
I don't have to keep coming back and
forth and just pick one thing and then
be like wow what else is out there I
have an idea so I like getting a lot of
information so I can make the best
decisions true
arrival
I wonder if the tile world is like cars
the do you see that new 2023
matte ceramic White Tile yeah yeah I bet
it's new and improved compared to the
old one I bet 100 I bet they'd be like
that like they're telling like all the
companies are like this just came in
they're like oh [__] then answer me this
how come I never seen a tile commercial
before
you never looked where are you looking
uh I don't know you never looked at tile
commercials there's Taco what the place
before movies or what
come check out these Caesar Stones those
are previews those are also commercials
it tells you to buy a Coke and some
gummy bears because that's the movie
commercial have you seen a Super Bowl
Halftime Tower commercial I don't know I
never really looked when I was never old
like this I'm old now so I'm looking at
different things what I'm saying oh
that's true like life support I'm
looking at that now it looks pretty good
to you I mean I'm seeing it for the
first time you know what I mean which
tells me
damn you're old
well
back just gave up
[Music]
oh yeah that looks good
oh it looks good in the light too yeah
and this one too just so you know like
so that's the piece in the Potenza
family right there this piece doesn't
have a lot of movement to it this as a
family doesn't have a ton of movement to
it but as you can see like these are the
other colors in the series yeah so
you'll get this color with that type of
movement to it I see yeah
oh man I wish I had the brain space to
like go okay this much space that's what
it's gonna look like yeah it's hard you
know because you're like little pieces
that I'm like
like on this it looks good but once you
like scale it out you're like
and that is that oh so that's the exact
version that's the exact version wow
just it being smaller looks different
and the lighting too has a lot oh right
the lighting hits it yeah we always
recommend somebody takes a sample home
with them yeah uh because you know
sunlight is gonna that's true I'm sure
you're gonna put this outside the
sunlight's gonna look way different than
this good call
this is only printed on the top right so
it is correct that however porcelain
tiles most of our porcelain tiles are
glazed porcelain the glaze that they put
on top of it is very very strong I see
okay
it's a [__] plane okay I just hit my
head and I still feel it I walked around
and I just went tall people I don't know
what the [__] maybe because like my
glasses free I don't know whatever
um so we're taking some samples home I
honestly didn't even know
[Music]
it's not suggested it because it's on
door lighting
um it's like this blue tint and then
obviously outdoor lighting is going to
be different especially depending on the
day too so he's like you know what the
ones that you like I'll give you a
sample take it home lay it out see how
you like it
gave us two of the
four that we wanted
the other one is like a natural stone
both of them yeah but I gotta just see
um
then in terms of design but in in terms
of function and how they were going to
cut it up because you know it's all
gonna look different
now they just kind of gave us these
standard sizes
um even these guys like when they come
smaller it's gonna look different so
yeah
um
to get my list ready and then I'll talk
to my landscaper and be like okay these
are like our ABC choices a is this if
it's out of budget going to be a lot of
options
way too much
all right so this seems already helpful
we're at spot number two and there's
already images of pools
so I feel like I don't have to use my
imagination as much as the other place
is a strictly tile spot so yes I
understand tiles can be countertops it
can be floors it could be on the wall it
could be on the pool but that's not my
area of expertise I can't imagine it all
so when we're in there I felt lost
looking at this
way more okay I can see where it goes
how do you feel about that
yeah same thing I wasn't lost but I'm
like okay it's narrowed down for me so
it's
yeah I'd be sick if there's an actual
pool inside you know like a big water
like if I had a pool spot with tiles
I would probably have like three like
little baby pools to be able to see
it okay
look at that
see having something like
for you to look at see look at that you
can see the tile there right and you can
even see the steps that is so helpful oh
my God now I can see like okay I
understand because we actually have a
kitchen too yeah we do I mean that's
what we're picking it for
yeah
but I couldn't Envision I couldn't
Envision the tile on a on a kitchen
house I don't know what to pick but now
I get it now
oh welcome
[Music]
materials in different sizes because it
helps me Envision more stuff too that's
true this is marble huh but yeah I like
how see like this looks different from
this obviously the shading is different
but it helps you envision a little yeah
this is pretty cool there's more whites
on that side that is marble look do you
see a White's over there wait what's
that
marble this is nice too
pavers
oh I'm done with the paper
this one is more gray Tony that's more
warm yeah
yeah so that place was relatively small
because I think they
I mean as you can see they specifically
only work with
um pools so they didn't have too many
selection so it was really easy for us
to go in and out
um that showroom area was literally the
biggest part well like the the half of
the rest of the space so I just found
one tile that I liked it is travertine
which um from what the other guy said
isn't necessarily more or less expensive
than any other materials but depending
on like what you get
um it can get expensive so we don't
really know how much that costs I just
found one so we're gonna try to go to
one more spot
location number three this one is called
versatile versatile okay and still I
like that um and already you can see
they have a lot of
materials on display you have your pool
porcelain pavers outdoor natural stone
pavers patio and deck and so far the one
that caught my eye immediately was this
one I like this too and I think this is
a more expensive one God damn it yeah
but it looks dope though God damn it
looks it looks really dope why does dope
[__] cost more I know dope [__] can you
answer that
and then I kind of like these over here
too
it's more of like a natural stone so
they have the imperfections that I
actually really like Yeah because it
gives it so much more life and character
like this
yeah yeah it's nothing like this yeah
and I love that like this random hole
like it just looks so nice and that way
when taika puts his paint in there it'll
get stuck even longer yeah but it's
outdoors so I don't give a [__]
let's go inside
whoa look at these tiles this is
metallic
that's crazy look at this one it's like
a crazy Mosaic oh okay okay okay okay
what's the reason
oh man I like showrooms I like that you
can see it laid out so helpful yeah
which one you're looking at look how
pretty this thing is oh yeah
what that's cool
that's pretty cool all the hair is going
in there with catching the hair dude
what if you have to clean it how do you
fix it
the other one if you just like pop it
out right well I guess
people
so that last spot looked like they just
catered to indoor tiling even though
they did have a couple outdoor ones
whatever I showed you
um that was already in the outdoors
display that was like the pink that was
the peak of like what they had that
piqued my interest
um so would you say versatile isn't very
versatile it wasn't very versatile for
being versatile you know what I'm saying
um so now we are at our last and final
destination for this tile hunt and we
are at aquabella
I don't know what to expect because
we're still sitting out in the car yeah
Bella
why'd you say like that because I I
think I'm hungry and you're hungry we
just ate and I think I know but it was
like diet food you know what I mean it
gave me like this much rice flour or
what even though David's like what
should I get pizza no why'd you say that
David's like I don't know who the [__]
each brussels sprouts I do David A lot
of people eat brussels sprouts that's
why they sell them at a [__]
Supermarket or else I mean I'm good too
you've made them real good you know what
we told David that David well he thinks
I cook like a trash man
on a marriage maybe that's where I like
it
and I like the texture it's like very
grippy
it's quartz expensive I don't even know
I don't think so oh there's some samples
on the ground
that's a nice ones
so this is what this door looks like
it's interesting that every store has a
different way of portraying stuff
this one seems pretty pool friendly
though look at all that I'm getting a
dolphin tile
oh that's nice
looks really nice on camera too
oh these are pavers
there's Aqua Bella brochure
and you can see like all kinds of sample
holes in there oh very cool can you see
how they mix and match the tile and
stuff that might be helpful okay
these towels are CUNY look at that
I want the big shark face can we put a
big shark in the bottom of the pool
not like a permanent fixture he's only
gonna be five one year excuse me it's
gonna make you smile every time you jump
in no way I would be like this was such
a dumb idea look there's like lobsters
crabs
Stingray
son
all right so this one's gonna be a short
Vlog we pretty much just needed to do
some research on the tile places and we
kind of have a general idea of what's
going on
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna email
our landscaper uh because I still feel a
bit lost but I'll let them know uh the
last landscaper in La how we like to go
about it is them give us kind of like
you know what's above budget budget
what's below budget and then they
suggest some of the materials that still
are in line with our Creative Design
and then we can go from there but having
seen uh all the different availabilities
I think that does help out so now if
they were to like mention certain brands
like aquabella or m0 or whatever okay
cool I know what you're talking about oh
yeah okay yeah we could use that
material so I think that definitely does
help out so we don't have anything
conclusive at the end of this Vlog but
this is the start of us picking
materials which means we are getting
closer to completing our pool which
should be done by summer so I'm really
excited